schönen guten morgen und wir schauen
direkt live nach münchen dort an die s
bahnstation schäftlarn wo gestern ein
schrecklicher unfall passiert ist wir
sehen jetzt hier die live bilder an
diesem morgen ganz hinten noch den
unfallort die s bahn die dort weiter
steht die bergungsarbeiten abgeschlossen
aber jetzt beginnen dort natürlich die
untersuchungen am unglücksort
gestern ist es passiert 2 s bahn züge
rauschen mit voller wucht ineinander ein
mensch stirbt 18 menschen wurden zum
teil schwer verletzt es ist ein
unfassbares drama mitten zur
feierabendzeit und dass es ist der erste
blick gewesen in den unfall zug dann
kamen zahlreiche retter die menschen die
dort in den zügen saßen berichten sie
wurden aus den sitzen geschleudert als
diese züge zusammenprallten das ganze
ist auch noch passiert an einer böschung
einzug drohte dann auch noch abzustürzen
es war eine schwierige aufgabe für die
retter und es bleibt vor allem die frage
wer trägt die verantwortung wer ist
schuld an diesem schrecklichen unfall
und wir gehen gleich natürlich mit
unseren reportern an diesen unglücksort
aber wir schauen uns noch einmal an wo
das passierte ist also zur orientierung
einmal die karte dort von münchen das
ganze hat sich südlich von münchen
abgespielt ebendort ebenhausen
schäftlarn das ist so 20 kilometer etwa
entfernt vom zentrum von münchen dass
sie alle dass wir alle so gut kennen und
dorthin gehen wir jetzt noch einmal ganz
genau mit patricia
ganz genau kein wir schauen uns das
einmal hier nochmal animiert an was dort
gestern abend zur feier am zeit passiert
ist in bayern besuchen hier einmal
hinein gehen ganz in den südwesten von
münchen 20 kilometer entfernt ebenhausen
schäftlarn zwei züge der s 7 es ist
genau 16 uhr 35 rauschen zusammen der
eine ist stehen geblieben aber die spur
hier ist eingleisig und der andere
unterwegs richtung münchen rauscht volle
kanne hinein ein 24 jahre alter mann
stirbt 18 menschen werden zum teil
schwer verletzt es waren viele schüler
dort im waggon die menschen berichten
sie wurden aus den sitzen gerissen wir
konnten eben auch einen ersten blick in
den unfall zug werfen dort die
zerstörung sichtbar und wir fragen uns
natürlich heute an diesem tag wer trägt
schuld daran wer hat die verantwortung
für das was hier passiert ist zwei züge
2 s bahn stoßen mit voller wucht
ineinander und ein mensch stirbt dabei
wir haben mit augenzeugen gesprochen die
gestern bei diesem schrecklichen unfall
dabei waren ich wollte jetzt fragen ob
die trinken oder essen möchte weiß dass
ich was ist zu hause haben dass ich hier
bin ist viel arbeit noch doch ich weiß
nie wie lange gedauert als wirklich die
leute zu sehen und ist nicht mehr normal
ich war ja noch in der arbeit wo es ging
da wurde einfach nur passiert ist ich
kann mir erst später zum einsatzort die
eltern haben sich natürlich sagen immer
wir sind von sollen gekommen haben
gemerkt dass die feuerwehr und polizei
und krankenwagen unterwegs ist
und dann haben halt gemerkt dass das ist
da und nicht mehr weiter geht man denkt
dann so ist die tägliche strecke nach
hause gewesen wäre es ein 2 s bahn
später gewesen da werde ich halt mit
dabei gewesen
ja glück gehabt in dem fall aber eben
ein toter viele verletzte 18 verletzte
unsere reporter sind gestern natürlich
sofort an diesen unfallort geeilt sind
bis jetzt dort wir sehen peter wilke
dort am unglücksort ganz in der nähe
peter wir haben gerade diese
augenzeugenberichte gehört wie erlebst
du jetzt die atmosphäre da am
unglücksort vor allen dingen auch unter
den die ja s bahn fahren müssen die auch
heute wieder in eine bahn steigen
mussten
ja es ist wirklich eine sehr bedrückte
stimmung hier wir können uns das im
hintergrund anschauen wir sehen die
polizeikräfte ganz am ende eben immer
noch die verunglückte s-bahn die jetzt
gleich geborgen werden soll und wir
sehen es im hintergrund hier leben viele
menschen hier sind wohnhäuser hier leben
familien direkt eben an diesen
s-bahngleisen die gefährt förmlich da
durch den garten kurzform garten fährt
geht diese s-bahn-strecke ändern und
eben kurz vom garten ist auch gestern
hier dieses unglück passiert und wir
konnten mit einer jungen frau sprechen
die eben hier lebt und die uns erzählt
hat sie wäre gestern hier gewesen als
das passiert ist hätte diesen lauten
knall diesen unheimlich lauten knall
gehört und dann wäre sie direkt dorthin
geeilt und hätte den menschen aus der s
bahn
wolfen hätte irgendwie versucht erste
hilfe zu leisten und eben menschen aus
den waggons zu retten und die polizei
ist dann ja auch relativ schnell hier
gewesen und musste tatsächlich auch
menschen rausschneiden aus diesen
trümmern befreien ich habe auch gerade
mit all dem örtlichen metzger gesprochen
er war zuerst nicht da der hat aber dann
auch alles in bewegung gesetzt sofort
als er von diesem unglück erfahren hat
eben seine ganzen wurstwaren hierhin
geschafft um versorgung zu leisten um
verpflegung zu leisten für die retter
aber auch eben für die verunglückten und
er hat gesagt auch er hätte sowas in
seinem ganzen leben noch nicht erlebt so
viel blaulicht so viele einsatzkräfte
das hat ihn wirklich geschockt aber man
muss sagen dieses beschauliche örtchen
hier steht in diesem stillen moment
trotzdem zusammen und hilft sich
gegenseitig hinter wilke vielen
herzlichen dank und wir gehen direkt
rüber zu wolfgang ranft er stets dort am
unglücksort fort an der s-bahnstation
der die rettungsarbeiten gestalteten
sich natürlich als schwierig dann auch
ein zug der drohte eine brücke eine
böschung herunter zu fallen musste
gesichert werden wolfgang was kannst du
uns berichten dass die retter erzählt
haben
also hier stehen 15 stunden nach dem
unfall die beiden s bahn immer noch in
verteilt ineinander hinter mir sieht man
die beiden
führerstände nach auf die linke seite
hin das ist die erst man die aus
wolfratshausen kam auf die rechte seite
hin das ist die s bahn die aus münchen
gekommen ist man sieht wie die wucht des
zusammenpralls gewesen ist die große
frage ist natürlich jetzt die muss auch
die bahn heute klären warum sind diese
beiden s-bahnen auf diesem einen gleis
gewesen laut fahrplan hätten sie hier
gar nicht sein so sollen sie hätten sich
in einer ganz anderen station die
ungefähr fünf kilometer nach norden
liegt begegnen sollen die es dort
zweigleisig und da hätten sie aneinander
passieren können und ihre fahrt
fortsetzen können ironischerweise ist
auch der bahnhof hier in ebenhausen
zweigleisig auch da hätten sie gefahrlos
passieren kann die frage ist warum sind
beide gleichzeitig los gefahren die eine
aus dem bahnhof heraus und die andere
wollte hinein das ist ja auch
interessant was du sagst wolfgang dass
die bahn laut fahrplan dort gar nicht
hätten sein dürfen eigentlich zu diesem
zeitpunkt gar nicht gleichzeitig hätten
dort sein können das ist eine
eingleisige
jetzt haben wir gehört in den
vergangenen stunden es hat da schon mal
einen vorfall gegeben vor wenigen
monaten sind dort zwei züge aufeinander
zu gefahren die konnten dann gerade noch
rechtzeitig zum stehen kommen so 100 150
meter voneinander entfernt war das
bekannt dass diese eingleisige strecke
dort eine problem strecke ist
also es gibt immer wieder solche
probleme weil vor allem die s bahn in
münchen hat auch eine große neigung dazu
verspätungen zu haben besonders am
späteren teil des tages und dann
passieren offensichtlich viele
ungeplante zusammentreffen bei diesem
zwischenfall der vier kilometer südlich
von hier passiert ist konnte
offensichtlich beide fahrer sich noch
rechtzeitig sehen dass sie aufeinander
zufahren und konnten den zug noch zum
stillstand bringen aber das wird
natürlich weiter fragen auf wie ist die
streckensicherung hier wie ist die
kontrolle das nicht ein zug auf eine
strecke fertig schon von einem anderen
zug belegt ist und da erwarten wir
durchaus noch aufklärung von der bahn
bei der unfallermittlungen
wolfgang du hast mit den rettern
gesprochen die dort vor ort eingetroffen
sind kurz nachdem das ganze unglück
passiert ist jemand vom technischen
hilfswerk ist auch bei dir was kann er
die berichten ja
ich habe ja andreas frank vom
technischen hilfswerk erfragen wie
sieht's im zug aus sie waren gestern
abend mehrere stunden gestern nach
mehrerer stunden darin unterwegs haben
aufgeräumt wie schaut's drin aus jeder
zuges leergeräumt die ganzen utensilien
gepäck sachen haben die fahrgäste
mitnehmen können ironischerweise gestern
war ein dienstag oben liegt noch einen
strauß roter rosen der waschechte endet
der partner gewesen ist das ist einzig
noch persönlich findet ansonsten ist
alles weg haben sie so einen einsatz von
einmal erlebt in dieser größe ich habe
es schon mehr erlebt ja in bad aibling
das war noch deutlich größer dieser
einsatz aber hier im landkreis münchen
ist das erste mal dass die sonne hinter
zu haben wie lange werden sie hier jetzt
noch arbeiten müssen was sind ihre
aufgaben noch die nächsten zwei tage
also jetzt geht es darum die
unterstützung bei der ermittlung der
unfallursache
wir müssen heute nacht wieder
ausleuchten und morgen früh kann dann
mit der bergung der beiden züge begonnen
werden zusammenarbeit mit der bahn
es wird also noch einige zeit dauern bis
wir hier wir eine freie strecke bekommen
in münchen der große bergungskran soll
so wie ich gehört habe erst morgen
kommen damit die züge voneinander
getrennt und vom gleis herr
untergebracht werden können weil auf dem
gleis können sie sich nicht mehr bewegen
ja was auch für eine psychische
belastung dafür die retter für die
menschen die die menschen raus holen
mussten dort aus den verkeilten zügen in
den vergangenen stunden danke euch danke
wolfgang danke peter an den unglücksort
in münchen
ein unglaubliches unglück was dort
passiert ist man muss sich das
vorstellen man dort mit der s bahn ist
es ja meiner heimat dort fährt es ist
eine absolute idylle in der nähe vom
starnberger see da schaut man verträumt
aus den fenstern und sieht wunderschöne
landschaften an sich vorbeiziehen das
ganze ist passiert 20 kilometer
südwestlich von münchen und wir müssen
uns die frage stellen wer trägt
verantwortung wer hat schuld daran dass
das passieren konnte und diese frage
wollen wir der bayerischen
verkehrsministerin stellen kerstin
schreyer uns jetzt auch zugeschaltet
schönen guten morgen wir wissen zu
diesem zeitpunkt sie ermittlungen sind
noch in vollem gange
dennoch haben sie irgendwelche
anhaltspunkte wie es zu diesem
schrecklichen unglück kommen konnte
also ich war gestern an der
unglücksstelle
man weiß eigentlich noch nicht viel man
weiß dass die zwei züge zusammengestoßen
sind alles andere ist völlig offen und
ich weiß es wird jetzt ganz viel
spekuliert aber ich glaube es ist jetzt
wichtig dass wir das gut untersuchen
denn nichts ist schlimmer als die
falschen schlussfolgerungen zur falschen
sachverhalt und jetzt muss man den
sachverhalt aufklären man muss es gut
ermitteln und dann auch daraus die
nötigen schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen
aber mehr als spekulation ist ja dass es
auf der strecke einige kilometer
entfernt vorerst einigen monaten einen
zwischenfall gegeben hat da sind auch
zwei züge aufeinander zugelassen und die
lokführer die haben gerade noch
rechtzeitig gebremst die waren damals
nicht ganz so schnell unterwegs und sind
dann ungefähr 100 150 meter entfernt
voneinander zum stehen gekommen war
ihnen bewusst dass das diese eingleisige
strecke dort eine problem strecke ist
wir haben ja viele eingleisige strecken
und ob das ein problem ist ist einfach
noch nicht klar wir wissen ja nicht ist
es eine technische frage ist es ein
menschliches versagen gewissens faktisch
nicht und ich glaube wir machen es uns
zu einfach wenn wir heute schon
behaupten dass die eingleisigkeit schuld
ist wir wissen es faktisch nicht und
erst muss man wissen was ist passiert
und daraus muss man ableiten was heißt
das dann nur was keinen sinn macht ist
dass man das was man schon immer
formuliert hat einfach wiederholt ohne
zu wissen ob es irgendeine ursache dazu
gibt für die hinterbliebenen auch für
die die dort in der s bahn saßen ist es
ganz wichtig dass jemand verantwortung
übernimmt war ganz oft ist es eben auch
so dass niemand verantwortung übernehmen
möchte wird das diesmal wieder so sein
das kann ich nicht beurteilen weil ich
faktisch die dinge nicht weiß wir müssen
es untersuchen und am ende des tages
wird wichtig sein was ein technischer
defekt war es eine menschliche frage
oder hätte man es auch verhindern können
oder was muss man tun damit so etwas
nicht wieder vorkommt und am ende des
tages muss ja das ziel immer sein dass
es null unfälle gibt und wir wissen alle
auf null werden wir es nicht schaffen
können und deswegen ist wichtig
anzuschauen was es passiert und daraus
dann entsprechend abzuleiten was muss
jetzt passieren damit es am besten nie
wieder einen unfall gibt das ist
passiert zur rushhour da waren sehr
viele menschen in der s-bahn sehr viele
menschen die da heute auch wieder fahren
werden in der ecke oder in den nächsten
tagen und diese gedanken immer wieder im
kopf haben werden die aber angewiesen
sind eben auf die s bahn was sagen sie
diesen menschen jetzt wenige stunden
nach dem unglück mit gefühl vielleicht
ja vielleicht auch mut machen für die
nächsten tage
ich glaube dass jetzt erst einmal der
zeitpunkt ist an die angehörigen des
verstorbenen zu denken und denen viel
kraft zu wünschen und es ist wichtig
dass wir an die verletzten denken und
denen wirklich wünsche ich von herzen
dass sie möglichst schnell wieder auf
die füße kommen und wir werden den ein
oder anderen auch haben denn die bilder
verfolgen werden denn es war schon ein
druck stark und so was ist ein ereignis
und
deswegen glaube ich dass wirklich es
wichtig ist dass sich jeder dann auch
die zeit nimmt die er braucht um mit
diesen bildern zurechtzukommen deswegen
war es aber auch wichtig dass gästen
dann der kriseninterventionsdienst da
war ich habe mit den personen auch
gesprochen die wirklich jeden einzelnen
begleiten es ist niemand allein
geblieben und wichtig wird sein dass man
eben sieht sowas soll nicht wieder
vorkommen und das andere ist dass
diejenigen die in der s-bahn fahren
heute werden wahrscheinlich einsteigen
zwar mit einem mulmigen gefühl aber sie
werden fahren denn es waren ja ganz
viele s-bahnen gottseidank unfallfrei
und das hilft im einzel nichts der in
diesem unfall drin war sagt kerstin
schreyer bayerischer verkehrsministerin
danke ihnen für das gespräch
bakogianni dankeschön also wir sehen es
sind viele fragen offen viele fragen die
sich all die menschen stellen sie dort
in den zügen saßen wir sehen hier jetzt
noch mal das livebild heute morgen die
beiden züge stehen da immer noch
ineinander verkeilt die retter versuchen
dort immer noch die situation zu lösen
gerade konnte uns einer der retter
schildern das einzige was man da auch
noch gesehen hat war ein strauß roter
rosen offenbar von jemandem der seine
liebste oder seinen liebsten überraschen
wollte ja dass in den stunden danach die
aufräumarbeiten die bergungsarbeiten
dort kurz vor dem abschluss die traurige
bilanz eben nach diesem ja s-bahn drama
von der gestrigen rush hour ein toter 18
verletzte und die große frage wer hat
eigentlich schuld daran die bleibt